كان الفوز الدبلوماسي للإدارة الرابحة
مع المملكة المتحدة التي
تمنع شركة هواوي الصينية العملاقة للتكنولوجيا
من الوصول إلى شبكتها اللاسلكية عالية السرعة ،
قالت بريطانيا في يناير إنه
يمكن استخدام معدات هواوي في شبكتها 5G على
أساس محدود
ولكن عكس مسارها يوم الثلاثاء وشبكة CNN.
shui spam
ينضم إلينا الآن على الهواء مباشرة من hong kong good
لرؤيتك Sharissa ما هو
التأثير المحتمل لهذا القرار
، التأثير المحتمل هو أن هذا
سيكون حقًا ضربة كبيرة
لهواوي وطموحاتها العالمية
قرار المملكة المتحدة بحظر huawei من شبكة 5G الخاصة بها
يرسل إشارة إلى البلدان الأخرى ، فإن المملكة المتحدة
تعتبر رائدة بعض الشيء عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالتقييمات الأمنية وفقًا
لمحلل تحدثت إليه
هذا الصباح وحقيقة أن المملكة المتحدة
اتخذت هذا القرار بأنه من
الخطر للغاية الآن استخدام huawei في 5g
الشبكة ستكون إشارة إلى
بلدان أخرى مثل بلجيكا
وفرنسا وألمانيا لتحذو حذوها
إما لتقييد huawei من
شبكات 5G الخاصة بهم
أو لحظرها جميعًا مثل المملكة المتحدة
الآن بالطبع تراجعت falway في
أه عن هذا القرار ووصفها بأنها
مخيبة للآمال قائلة إن هذا
يتعلق بسياستنا التجارية ولا يتعلق
بالمخاطر
الأمنية وبالطبع هذا مكسب كبير لـ
إدارة ترامب التي
كنت تعرف أنها أطلقت حملة ضغط
على هواوي في الجزء الأفضل
من عامين ، لكن كل هذه القرارات
تأتي أيضًا
مع اه مع تداعيات
ليس فقط لهواوي وليس فقط لنشر
شبكات 5 جي حول العالم
ولكن من المحتمل  بالنسبة للدول التي
تتخذ هذه القرارات ، تعد
هواوي بالطبع بطلًا وطنيًا ضخمًا
للصين
وكنا نشهد بالفعل
قبل صدور القرار في المملكة المتحدة
بالأمس وزارة الخارجية تلمح نوعًا ما
إلى
أن حظر هواوي من شبكات 5G
يمكن أن يتسبب في ضربة لتجارة الصين في المملكة المتحدة
، واليوم رأينا اليوم من
صحيفة تابلويد تديرها الدولة في الأوقات العالمية
افتتاحية بعنوان الصين لن تكون سلبية
شاهد
حظر huawei في المملكة المتحدة وإليك ما كتبوه
، من الضروري أن تنتقم الصين
من المملكة المتحدة
وإلا فلن يكون من السهل جدًا
التنمر ويجب أن يكون هذا الانتقام
علنيًا ومؤلماً بالنسبة للمملكة المتحدة
بحيث يكون إكليل الجبل تحذيرًا قويًا
جدًا للآخرين  البلدان التي قد
تفكر في اتباع نهج المملكة المتحدة